and before I introduce our next speaker
I want to share with you some sneak
insights into the global rankings the
latest global rankings with regard to
fiber-to-the-home penetration throughout
the globe and we will have a session
session two after lunch which we'll do a
deeper dive on these figures but I just
want to share with you some of the
highlights that we've uncovered for this
year and firstly to begin it's with
great relief that I get to announce that
the UAE has the number one position for
fiber-to-the-home penetration throughout
the world with a whopping greige 93.7%
penetration rate which is fantastic and
for me personally I applaud that I think
that's a great achievement the reason I
say it's with great relief is I met with
some of the operators down there late
last year and they were extremely
passionate about their number one
position in fiber-to-the-home rankings
throughout the world and they were very
vocal about ensuring that they could
retain that position and they were
putting massive investment in to ensure
that they retained that position I
genuinely wish we could see that same
level of passion across the European
states I'm also thrilled to announce
that we have a new number-one position
within the EU and they are in 8th
position globally with a fantastic 45.2%
penetration ratio and that's for Latvia
who have now taken the crown off
Lithuania who held that for a number of
years so they should be applauded as
well on their efforts
Spain continues to power ahead and where
they've managed to accelerate into 19th
position globally with a twenty four
point nine percent penetration rate I
urge you to keep in mind where they
where four or five years ago that's a
fantastic achievement and something that
should be recognized our hosts here in
France are doing extremely well as well
France
thanks to all the recent investments in
fiber at home now sees a penetration
rate of 11 point one percent and again
keep in mind their investments have only
started in the last few years so you
know they've really picked up the pace
quite quickly and finally we have two
new entrants into our panorama and for
those who are not familiar with the
rules of our panorama the rules of our
panorama state that for a country to get
enlisted within the panorama it must
have a minimum of two hundred thousand
households and also it must have a
minimum of 1% connected homes and we've
got two new entrants that are joining
this year in Austria and Serbia so
welcome to the club guys hopefully this
is the start of many great things to
come as we go forward
as I mentioned session 2 after the break
we'll go into much more detail with
regard to the latest fiber-to-the-home
figures so if you want to bring yourself
up to speed that's the place to go
ladies and gentlemen it's a real honor
to welcome our next keynote speaker a
fellow Irishman our speaker is a
barrister he's been a lecturer in public
law and Trinity College in Dublin
followed by a number of years as legal
secretary in the chambers of advocate
general at the European Court of Justice
he's subsequently a member of the legal
service of European Commission and he
was head of cabernet private office for
the EU Commissioner Nellie CROs when she
was commissioner for competition and
then later when she became Commissioner
for the Digital Agenda please give a
warm welcome to our second keynote
speaker mr. Anthony Whelan director for
electronic communication electronic
communications networks and services
with the European Commission
consignee thank you for joining us
so the format that we're going to work
to within this session we're going to
have a Q&A session with Anthony and he's
going to share some of the very
important insights and that are emerging
from within the Commission um I'm gonna
kick off proceedings if that's ok and
where I'd like to raise the question
with regard to the new gigabit target
set by the EU Commission and why did the
Commission feel that an update to the
connectivity targets was timely given
that the original targets were still to
be achieved for 2020
that's a good question Ronan because of
course we have targets in place as you
say which have a very general scope they
were focused on on rollout throughout
the European territory mainly for
residential end users the idea being
that everyone would have 30 megabits per
second available to them and that at
least 50% would be subscribing to 100
megabits per second so why move on those
standards are of course still valid
because we we need to keep
predictability for people who are
organizing either public policy
interventions or private market efforts
around targets which are meant to give
visibility to to all the actors in the
ecosystem but in order to give
visibility forth is now a three to four
year perspective isn't really good
enough anymore so we need to look beyond
that's that's why we fix basically a a
new horizon of 2025 based on experience
based on identified new needs and based
also on a greater degree of
prioritization we distinguish for
example three targets one of them for
the socio-economic drivers so that the
multi-user centers like businesses
public administrations and schools which
will clearly be those with the most
immediate needs but also demand pullers
within their community for full rollout
we have a 5g target because increasingly
we are seeing that
and Wireless are not separate universes
on the contrary
so we aim for at least one major city in
each member state to have of commercial
5g service by 2020 with wider rollout
including transport routes by 2025 and
then because the the digital divide
general service challenge is still there
we aim for 100 megabits per second
available to all by 2025
Antoine mentioned earlier speed is not
everything I know everything I've just
said is articulated in terms of speed
political targets of course have a
certain simplifying logic because you
have to draw the attention of
decision-makers who are not engineers or
specialists but when you dig down into
the whole policy narrative that we
develop around it of course we are in
focused on more than gigabit speeds
we're looking at latency were looking at
resilience we're looking at an array of
parameters that different users will
need very good thank you Tony this is
the first time that the Commission has
proposed very high capacity connectivity
to become a regulatory objective
embedded in the regulatory framework of
the EU what is the rationale behind us
proposal why would it be important for
very high capacity connectivity to be a
regulatory objective for nras and
secondly waters the Commission's vision
of very high capacity connectivity if
you allow it to but I might take it the
other way around
the vision and then why we pump it into
the into the regulatory framework
building on what I just said that we we
see needs that need to be prioritized
looking out to 2025 which at least for
certain user groups will certainly be
very demanding we see a need to actually
define the ambition an ambition that is
corresponding to the needs obviously and
there we find it very difficult to close
our eyes to the fact
that we see very high-performance
technologies that tick all the boxes
that are available to us I don't need to
say what it is in this room although we
are sometimes attacked for simply
mentioning the word fiber in in any
regulatory context but sometimes you
must call a spade a spade we see a role
to define our ambition relative to what
we know and what we know includes what
we know about technology which is not
the same as saying that we then do a
command economy with only one technology
acceptable or allowed why put it into
the regulatory framework for at least
two reasons one is just to have a
coherence across instruments we talk
about targets and technologies in the
area of state aid control for example we
of course are very directly involved in
trying to promote ro light by various
actors through EU structural funds we
are working with the EIB on a broadband
fund it seems only normal that we try to
get coherence across instruments
including regulation the second
linked reason is that we have a
regulatory framework that was designed
to promote competition and then you and
user benefits which remain of course
absolutely key but we think it is useful
to define outcomes that we would like to
see emerging from competition to divine
outcomes that we would regard as
corresponding to end-user interest and
that for us is the roll out and take-up
roll out alone is not enough of a very
high capacity networks thank you and in
your opinion what do you see is the key
regulatory levers that the Commission
has proposed to foster ubiquitous very
high capacity connectivity there are
quite a few and the I will I will
perhaps separate for convenience fixed
and wireless even though the reality of
course is that
they come together our main regulatory
lever on unfixed is the way in which we
regulate access to networks and the
economic environment that that creates
we see a real opportunity to favor
infrastructure competition by putting
focus on access to the assets that help
alternatives to build out and to create
the incredible threat that they will
build out so a big focus on access to
decks and polls where where they are
available we see an important general
change in the regulatory environment
that we we seek to focus regulated
access to where it is really needed
where competition can't you easily
develop on its own so where it is
possible we try to favor it and let it
do its work where it is not of course we
still need competitive access in order
to make sure that end-users I serve but
what that leads to hopefully is more
focused regulation and therefore greater
scope for what you might call animal
spirits to be to be released in the
sector but without removing the key role
of regulation to favor competition that
that remains key but wherever possible
competition to roll out should should be
prioritized and thirdly on the fixed
side we see because the sector has
developed in a variety of different ways
since this framework was first created
we see a need to send signals on how
certain specific business models will be
treated so that everyone gets
predictability co-investment models all
sell only models for example which can
be models better associated with
ambitious with ambitious deployment
goals on the wireless side it's mainly
about how we create favorable investment
conditions through the assignment of
spectrum to two players in the market
and we see a number of key ways to do
that one of them is long term
predictability on the
ability of spectrum and getting spectrum
quickly into the market another which is
very much linked to fiber backhaul
issues is greatly easing any
administrative constraints that may
exist for small cell deployment a small
cell is not a wireless mast it shouldn't
be subject to the same planning controls
absolutely make sense with regard you've
you've just mentioned to investment
models or business models Co investment
and a wholesale only business model why
was it really specifically that a
commission felt that there are special
rules needed for these two business
models to be embedded in the European
legislative framework and what is it
more specifically that you're proposing
for these two models why are they so
different from let's say the vertically
integrated investment model yeah what
maybe just to lead into that I should
say as part of the general refocusing of
access regulation we also foresee even
for the more classical business models
for example greater pricing flexibility
because we think that is an important
opportunity for players to make
long-term decisions on on investments in
networks then then looking at those
specific cases I there are not many if
any wholesale only players who are
currently regarded as dominant but we
also see very local developments and
markets and market analysis may change
so we need to give players who are
investing sometimes in very ambitious
networks predictability on what might
happen if they're every deemed to be the
only game in town in their respective
areas the most important thing there I
think is that we would not see price
regulation as being the norm it should
be something that can perhaps be held in
reserve by regulators for cases where
abusive behavior is
is detected because typically a
wholesale only player has an incentive
to sell to all the players in the market
and to and to enhance capacity take up
on the co-investment side we what we see
as an opportunity is that if there are
credible threats by alternative players
to build it makes it more attractive for
dominant players to co-invest rather
than to as a way to sit on their hands
but you need to be sure that
co-investments take place on terms which
allow smaller players to genuinely take
part to present them where the real
investment opportunity but also a real
reason to Co invest which is that once a
co investment opportunity is made
available it can't simply be like before
that one would take the option while I
wait and see we are trying to put it up
to everyone in such a case to to invest
together you you minimize over all
Catholics while keeping sustainable
competition opportunities on the network
that is built because everyone has
defined conditions for for access to the
capacity you have also mentioned that
the Commission seeks to enhance the
investment I environment for wireless
networks
what is it more specifically that you're
proposing you've mentioned the 25 years
long licenses but what else is it that a
commission is proposing to harmonize
across Europe to help ultimately 5g
network development yeah and an array of
issues some things of course we can do
with current tools identifying and
harmonizing relevant spectrum including
in much higher parts of the spectrum is
something we're already working on with
the Member States and and moving ahead
quite quickly but technical
harmonization has its limits the the
conditions under which spectrum is put
into the market
we'll be pretty decisive to determine
how quickly and and how deeply 5g is
rolled out so in addition to long term
horizons the acceleration of the
assignment of new bands is something
that we think we feel new European tools
for we think we need to have a clear
opportunity under the spectrum rules for
unlicensed spectrum and the spectrum
sharing because with the new types of
bands that you will use four four four
5g the traditional models which will
remain very valid of course for for the
seven eight hundred nine hundred bands
of individualizing NSYNC need to be
complemented it's not a matter of one
over the other but of having a full full
toolbox and we need spectrum regulators
there have been some bumps in the road
in the last few years to learn from each
other and that for us is imagine not of
harmonizing but of putting spectrum
regulators together to give advice to
each other to share best practices and
to avoid some of the mistakes of the
past when regulating a dynamic industry
with rapid technological developments
such as our telecoms industry how can we
ensure the regulatory environment does
not hamper innovation for example when
we look at some of the new innovations
coming then to track like network
slicing etc how do we ensure that some
of the current policies that are in
place do not hamper the innovation that
we can expect to see in the future I I
think I'm most regulators act by the the
mater of first do no harm so we always
try I think this is as true of the
national regulators that we interact
with as it is of the Commission we try
to avoid solving problems before they
even appear because the they may not
appear in the in the shape that we know
but at the same time to create frame
so that people have a certain idea of
how things may pan out that may seem a
bit contradictory but that's how the
world is best example using the network
slicing case you mentioned there was a I
think I a good deal
one might say more heat than light
generated over the last two or three
years on net neutrality rules in Europe
and how they would pan out in particular
for for future networks I I think in the
legislative process on those rules and
then in the more detailed guideline
development with the NRA Xin in beric we
we have found good clear principles to
work by there is a clear opening in the
legislation for different types of
enhanced value optimized quality
services to meet specific needs the
guidelines developed by Barrack have
signaled among other things very
explicitly this is a big demand from the
secretary that Network slicing is one
possible means by which these sorts of
optimized services can be provided it
doesn't say much more than that and
that's probably good because we we don't
know exactly what sort of specific
challenges these sorts of of new ways of
managing networks will throw up but as
long as they are developed in ways that
maintain a fair allocation of capacity
to your general internet service then
I'm sure we we're on a good path and
perhaps the most important thing is that
there is a shared understanding among
regulators is that this is not a
permission to innovate system no one has
to come and apply to the Commission or
Barrack or to any race to provide a
so-called specialized service they
develop it they develop the use case
that it corresponds to and they will
respond to questions if asked but but
that's that's how it will work very good
thank you very much and we have a number
of questions in from Twitter and I think
we've got some time and to go through a
couple of them at least
as about maybe you want to start we have
a few questions I think which relates to
the acceleration of adoption in demand
can public sector Kim regulators do more
actually to help demand increase for
very high capacity connectivity I I
think it is difficult for for regulators
in the sense of market regulators to to
bring forward demand it depends upon the
scope of their of their competences and
the you cannot legislate demand into
existence
you can favor demand by making sure that
the supply into the market is
competitive because then you will in
principle have a price that that that
that promotes demand and I think your
own numbers show that when investments
are made in our generally competitive
European markets the take-up follows in
what we the Commission have called a
virtuous circle o of build up build out
and take up so that market assurance
aspect isn't directly demand creating
that it is certainly demand enhancing
our that of course there's a whole array
of areas where the public sector can
lead in education for example in the
connecting of schools which is which is
one of our one of our targets children
will not only be better educated and
more ready for for the future society
and the economy but they will also be
demand vectors in in their own homes if
I may say health services public
services these are all an important part
of that and the public sector has an
important role to get out of the way of
demand I get back to things like
planning and and other restrictions or
electromagnetic restrictions which are
which are you know fractions of
recommended World Health Organization
levels these all make Network Bildad
more expensive not just for wireless but
also for the battle that that underpins
it and we probably have time for one
quick
last one there was one that was on the
screen just previously it's rolled off
now but it's with regard to how can we
accelerate there are certain countries
that it saddens me to say our Lagarde's
with regard to the adoption of broad
fibre to deployment how can we really
motivate them to engage in a more
broader fashion for deploying fibre to
the home to its citizens or fiber to you
know the antenna if it's part of a fire
G system for example I I think there are
some countries who have been let's say
historically very happy to see perhaps
more rapid but also more shorter and
investments who are beginning to see
that longer-term ambition is important
for their overall policy mix in part and
this gets back to the question of
targets they are of course not
everything or far from it but in part
what gets measured gets done and Antoine
earlier pointed out that on one of the
measures that we have been using to date
or of general next-generation access
roll out France was not doing so well I
think it was 50% for for the last year
relative to 70% plus at the European
level which is taking a sort of 30
megabits per second benchmark if the
benchmark becomes 100 megabits per
second for all by 2025 it may be that
France suddenly looks very different
just to speak of of where we are in that
case and in the the speaking of
Marseille or the the French Connection
takes on a whole new and more more
positive spin because they have taken
perhaps a more slow-burning but but
longer-term approach to the networks
they feel they will need in future so
into interstate competitive forces
should help continue to drive things
it's part of it very good very good
well ladies and gentlemen thank you very
much time Tony Whelan please give her a
warm round of applause for
along today
[Applause]